chaque jour qui passe nous relatons dans
nos journaux d'information la terrible
escalade de la violence entre israéliens
et palestiniens à une violence qui pour
les populations de la région constitue
un traumatisme psychologique terrible
dans la bande de gaza une équipe de
médecins sans frontières tente d'aider
les familles palestiniennes dont les
maisons et parfois même les vies ne sont
plus que des ruines reportage claude
sans père est à la bourre année c'est sa
première visite de la journée
muriel vient voir la famille salamin
rafah au sud de la bande de gaza muriel
vit d'habitude à toulouse depuis un mois
elle travaille ici comme psychologue
pour médecins sans frontières la maison
de la famille salama se trouve à moins
de 100 mètres d'un poste militaire
israélien quand des combattants
palestiniens viennent dans le secteur la
réplique israélienne est immédiat ils
tirent depuis cette position militaire
israélienne
ça traverse la porte et crible ce mur il
tire souvent on ne peut plus vivre là et
on a dû passer du deuxième étage au
premier la première chose qui est très
très important c'est d'eux qu'il me
montre tout ça depuis ce témoigner de ça
et puis ensuite une fois que les
personnes ont pu montrer tout ça on
commence à travailler sur des choses
comme la peur sur ce qu'ils peuvent
ressentir la nuit dans la culture
palestinienne il est parfois difficile
de parler de sa souffrance
les hommes surtout ne veulent pas passer
pour des faibles muriel essaye donc de
garder un contact régulier avec ces
familles dans le quartier les bulldozer
israélien ont déjà détruit une vingtaine
de maisons au milieu des ruines quelques
enfants s'amusent à ramasser début de
bals où les restes de grenade sela ward
après la famille salama muriel rencontre
leur voisin lui aussi malgré les risques
préfère continuer à vivre ici c'est
quelqu'un
qui va pas bien du tout parce que ça se
confirme c'est d'entendre suis
constamment pour protéger sa famille
dont il a loué une maison pas très loin
d'ici
donc ses enfants et sa femme dormait là
bas et lui tout est mis médecins sans
frontières avait au départ prévu de
rester trois mois à gaza depuis la
mission est sans cesse prolongés et
muriel pour l'heure n'a qu'une envie
continuer son travail malgré toutes les
difficultés